ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillan show this is a this is a tough
one this week this is not the easiest
one to
do uh this is a high degree of
difficulty the routine uh if you ever
watched the gymnastics in these Summer
Olympics when they go the routine that
uh she will
be attempting this evening has a high
degree of difficulty she stumbled many
times during practice she has a lot of
Maneuvers in there she's unfamiliar with
and she had some real trouble she had
real trouble during practice let's see
if she's worked those Kinks out that's
uh that's what we got today because
we've had a week um and no matter what I
say about anything today on this
show somebody's going to be upset that I
didn't say more or I said the wrong
thing or I mean something different than
what I said or I don't have the facts
and if I had the facts I'd think
differently there's no way to avoid that
I'm one of the greatest minds of our
time and and watching me in real
time put this together is got to be one
of the greatest joys in what I imagine
is a horrible life that you live on the
other end of that uh camera I don't know
I'm guessing some of you are doing fine
but a lot of you let's be honest and uh
watching the mental dexterity me just
jumping into it you know no script no
talking points Barry Weiss by the way
was supposed to come and do the show and
and de ghosts me at the last minute
because it's been a very bad week for
Israel I think it's been a good week for
her career not for her cuz I like Barry
and I know it's a horrible week for
everyone that's Je Jewish and everyone
that's been Jewish or knows someone
who's Jew I get it uh but she's in
demand that's what I'm saying do you see
this is a high degree of difficulty I'm
still on the balance beam I swayed a
little bit you thought I was gonna but
I'm still on
it um but no she's in demand it's not a
good week for her it's not what I mean
what I mean is that a lot of people are
calling her probably that far exceed the
uh you know reach that I have for
example even though my reach is
incredibly large um and she would be
honored to be here and should have
texted me back but I'm not mad at her
because I understand that it is tough
but now here's what she gets I'm going
to do it on my own I have my own ideas
and I am going to go with that now she
had the chance to come and and speak her
peace well we'll start at the
beginning there's something called The
Bible and
no as anybody uh everybody now knows
there was a horrific attack in Israel
Hamas which is a terrorist group they're
running Gaza but they can't do that well
they're not good at that they're they're
proven that they're not bad at terrorism
that's what they're good at but they're
not they can't run Gaza that which is
their you know which is the I told you
folks this is a this is you've never
seen anything like this how impressed
are you already you've never even been
in a room with someone capable of doing
anything like what you're about to see
Hamas is a terrorist
organization that was actually formed uh
somewhat
funded by Israel because Israel was
trying to discredit some more of the
moderate factions of the
PLO and which is the
Palestine
Liberation
Organization MH so
Israel was kind of funding Hamas the way
that we funded Al alqaeda when it was
the mujahadin against the Soviets in
Afghanistan we built
that so it's often these things happen
right when you when you feed you know
there are two wolves inside of you which
one do you feed and where when you feed
something it can grow there can be
unintended
consequences um so Hamas is this
terrorist group and we all have some
varying degree of familiarity with Hamas
they are not the Palestinian people uh
they are not rep representatives of the
Palestinian people they are terrorists
um whose goal is the Eraser of Israel
they don't want it to exist they from
the blank to the Sea whatever from the
you know that's the slogan again Barry
Weiss uh just not here so I'm doing all
I can do I'm not I from what I got a lot
of stuff I got to do I have a lot of
projects going on I'm devoting my time
to this so I'm not going to have every
eye you
know it and the point is from the what
is the quote from the something to the
Sea it's the quote they always say which
means that there'll be no Israel it'll
just be Palestine from The River To The
Sea they don't want Israel to
exist uh Hamas it's not like they want a
two-state
solution they're not like trying to
co-exist um they are they want to
eradicate Israel and I don't think
that's controversial uh you know I think
they would admit that I think they kind
of open about that and then you see this
crazy attack they are murdering women
and children and elderly people and and
and concert goers that were at a music
festival and horrible ways you
know it's
it's this situation over there has made
both sides see each other as less than
human and the only way that you can do
what Hamas did to people is if you see
them as less than human in the same way
that if a
Palestinian uh teenager whatever gets
shot in the West Bank or in Gaza by uh
an Israeli security guard a member of
the military and they just kill somebody
in Cold Blood the only way you can
really do
that the want and Slaughter of people is
if you see them as less than
human which is when you see stuff like
that cuz we're we're soft I'm pretty
soft now I I don't
encounter things like that ever like in
my real day-to-day life
like that type of violence that type of
even hatred that type of
desperation I I did when I when I when I
was um uh broke I was uh around a lot of
people or when I was doing drugs I knew
a lot of people who were desperate and
uh more violent you know because that
comes with the territory of being a drug
addict um that being said to live a life
like I live and most of my friends live
where we entertain people we make people
laugh we eat we drink we make Merry we
have our problems or whatever but when
you
see the vicious assault on on infants on
women on on
children uh it's unbelievable it's
unfathomable that anyone could do that
to anyone else
um and that's what Hamas did they they
had this attack that was there's now
conflicting reports of whether Iran knew
about it or was caught by
surprise if Iran was funding it with the
$6 billion that they got in the Iran
deal um nobody knows people
are still seemingly pretty vague about
like what Iran knew and didn't know Iran
supports uh Hamas uh Hezbollah which is
a militia in uh
Lebanon and so people are trying to put
that together um so we all wake up this
was a last Saturday
to this crazy [__] I don't even do an
episode I go release the episode that we
had in the can with the guys from areu
garbage whom I
adore that was going to get held till I
was in Australia I'm leaving for
Australia tonight I'm I'm in California
right now today is Wednesday just in
case something happens tomorrow I you
want to be when things like this happen
you want to be clear about what you're
saying and when um so I just said I woke
up I'm like I really can't go in and
make any type of joke about this it's
inhuman I had to wait a few days to even
process and understand what was
happening
um and uh so you know I'm just watching
all this stuff happen and it's uh M so
now of
course Israel is you know it's a war
they've declared war
and they're now you know bombing Gaza
and now there is probably a human
itarian crisis on the other end whereas
Gaza
civilians are dying as well just like
Israeli civilians died This Is War this
is what happens this is ugly and so a
few thoughts because I'm I'm watching
the reactions to
this on social media and the first
thought that I had was
that it was very interesting by the way
to say people like Amy Schumer or or or
these other celebrities finally start
going like well these colleges a little
uh
liberal his colleges are a little woke
huh cuz all over American colleges now
they're doing kill the Jews everywhere
from Yale to Harvard to toughs where
those guys were on
paragliders going over the border into
Israel and then just shooting people
randomly and the kids at tough's
University were like well that's kind of
creative they were like that's pretty
smart um and those are things you say in
your dorm sh you you don't say them out
but you don't but they're saying them in
like law reviews they're writing them
down in pieces of paper that people can
look at years from now like you know I
think the NYU came out and was like all
of the violence that's going on is we
laid on the doorstep of Israel this is
all of these colleges are now saying
hey decolonized what do you think it
looks like what do you think it means it
means a couple of in
uh get killed couple of women and
children get killed and this is really
taken and black lives matter by the way
put up a get this up they put up like a
meme and they this is not even a thing
they had to make this they have a meme
of a parag of a guy in the
paraglider thing going I stand with
Palestine now you have to remember this
is on the day or maybe the day after
that the news broke where you were
seeing the most vicious horrific scenes
you've ever witnessed really I mean
really really bad now I'm not saying
that there aren't other things happening
that are just as bad or that if you look
you could find them I'm not I'm not a
naive [__] you guys know that you've
listened to this show but this is in
your feed you wake up you got the French
toast in your mouth and you're like God
it was crazy czy black lives matter
Chicago goes and tweets
that that that is all that is
it and it's I stand with pal gu now all
of these
celebrities had been duped for
years all you had to real all you had to
know is know what a con is I knew black
lives matter was a con because I knew I
know what cons are I worked in a
subprime mortgage office I know what
cons are I know the look and the smell
and the shape of a
con a con is pretty identifiable if you
if you know one or if you've seen one or
if you've pulled one and I knew exactly
what that was it was this very for
example do black lives matter like the
way you say everybody goes yeah like of
course like who's saying
no right so but then when you did the
tiniest amount of research into it it's
run by these four women they're all
avowed uh marxists meaning that they
don't believe in anything that people uh
you know purport to believe in in this
country they they think the nuclear
family should be abolished and
eradicated in favor of every the
government socially engineering and
managing everybody's life that was on
the BLM website front page but none of
these celebrities went there none of
them looked into any of the information
themselves none of them knew that that
[__] stole four houses and I'm I'm for
that but that [__] bought a bunch of
houses with the money that should have
went to people's families who died uh
with in in uh in shootouts with the
police so this it's always been a scam
and the things that they've believed
they've concealed them with a very like
uh
friendly uh you know and
non-controversial
[__] uh you know whatever you want to
call it logo which was like black lives
matter now the mask is kind of off
they're
tweeting we're with Hamas
essentially you know I stand with
Palestine now you can stand with
Palestine the idea that they should have
a state the idea that you should have a
two-state solution the idea that the
settlements are crazy that I'm going to
go into that in a minute but the idea
that you would tweet this the day after
and now all of these celebrity and I
know some of these people
and and and again they're they're
they're genuinely befuddled they're
confused they don't they don't get it
they I immediately get I'm shocked they
did that I wouldn't I don't know who at
the meeting said let's tweet that but
immediately I'm like he you didn't know
what they
believed you didn't know what they
really thought but these people
didn't so that all of these people now
like I I saw Jessica s F did Instagram
post today she's like these universities
are
liberal and I'm like okay hello Jordan
Peterson welcome to
reality like welcome to the reality that
most people live in anybody that pointed
out that college kids had gone a little
nuts over the past four years was hered
by these people they were called a
boomer out of touch a racist a white
supremacist a xenophobe
uh a transphobe a homophobe all of these
people were like if you can't get on
board with college kids they're always
right every single person I know who's
writing College when when have they ever
been wrong all my comedian friends on
Twitter my writer friends that now live
in tents they were going what when where
college kids ever wrong they're always
on the right side of History why don't
you get with them and now the college
kids are literally in college going kill
the Jews kill the Jews
and that all of these people that gave
these organizations money this is a
little embarrassing huh awkward it's a
little strange all these people in real
time they're having like this weird
Awakening moment where they're like oh
okay because remember how simple
everything was during 2020 how simple
and easy it was it was the wrong side of
history and the right side of History
part of the problem part of the solution
took a page out of the Bush Doctrine
good or evil with us or against us now
people are starting to go wait a minute
uh these these college kids are a little
out of control they're a little out of
control um again this says nothing about
the political reality of the situation
which
is not
good very difficult folks you can see
right now on the floor exercise what Mr
Dylan excels at is artistry he's the
Artistry of what he does sometimes is
more than the technical and sometimes
the judges actually give him some points
for that he's actually puts on a real
show for the crowd he puts on a real
show for the crowd and you could see the
crowd getting into it he hasn't really
completed the same type of technical
Feats that other people have but he
really puts on a show for the crowd and
he reminds them that he is a performer
um Israel is the problem with Israel
kind of has always been they've never
been like hey here are the borders
here's where we're at they they they
kind of have always been a little cute
with their borders they
expand they build settlements they go
into areas where Palestinians can take
Deeds out and go I've owned this
property I've owned this land I've been
here forever and they evict Palestinians
and Palestinians are now homeless and
they're impoverished and this is a huge
problem and a lot of people are against
this and unfort fortunately it doesn't
seem like
America we give Israel a ton of money
but we don't hold them to account like
we don't demand certain things of them
we we we have in the past Bush one did a
little bit like there are times when we
have said listen we need to the idea of
a two-state solution the idea of like he
said but what we really do is we give
them a lot of money and then kind of
look the other way and go do whatever
you want and they expand the SLE you
know they expand the borders of Israel
these
settlements and and and whatnot and this
this this Gaza Strip that Palestinians
live in under this this Siege this blade
occupation whatever you want to call it
they're living in this I I it's an
incredibly densely populated region
where you cannot get a lot of things in
that you would need to survive they
cannot leave they are not allowed to
leave like one of the things Netanyahu
was like well the civilians I'm telling
you now to leave this we're going to
bomb you you got to leave where are they
gonna where are they going Palm Beach
where are they goingon to go they can't
go anywhere where are they goingon to go
there's nowhere for them to go now I'm
not saying Israel doesn't have a right
to Def if that happened anywhere in
America we'd be doing what they're doing
but the other thing I wanted to comment
on was as soon as this happened and and
now I've seen all these people statuses
and they're like we remember remember
the silence to people who were
silent and you go well what wait a
minute hold on hold wait hold the phone
a minute what do you want me to say what
do you really want people to say Israel
is going to
defend itself no matter what I
say there's like they don't need
me they don't need Instagram comments to
defend thems they're going to go do that
they're going to do whatever they want
and I understand after a heinous attack
like that there's justification for what
they do now now what they do and how far
it goes you can evaluate whatever but
there this whole idea that everybody
needs to speak up and be heard and be
counted no you don't know what people
are going to say listen let people stay
quiet it's actually good even if they
agree with you if people agree with you
still have them shut up they might hurt
your
cause they might hurt your cause I've
seen a lot of pro-israel people not help
recently I I checked in I check on all
the social media sites see what's going
on and I know a lot of my Long Island
friends are like they should just
genocide of all over there and it's like
that's just not helping but they're pro
Israel so the people that agree with you
sometimes are often the people you want
to
go you don't need everybody standing up
and talking We Know listen nobody's
outside of your kids at College nobody's
applauding this at time I mean some
people are you know but even GG Hadid
said no she goes I'm not let can you get
GG Hadid or Bella Hadid get one of the
Hadid statements up because it was
actually very nice she did a great job
my thoughts are with
those it's too long here's my point I'm
not doing this whole thing she's saying
hey you can't do
it but she's also saying she's kind of
doing what I'm
doing you know but I'm doing it in a
better way I think but she's saying
hey that's what she's saying that in a
word that's what she's saying it's a
three paragraph thing
but if if it had to be a tone it would
be this
hey hey it would start up and then go
down they would go be like hey and it
would kind of would have the guttural
ending of
like you know I don't know listen so you
have now a situation where everybody on
social media is like we will remember
the stence of you and you go good please
because the the the talking is no good
good that's not going to help your case
this is a like listen and then people
are like well it shouldn't be
complicated well I understand that but
it is everything is complicate nothing
is not
complicated yes is stabbing a woman in
her face comp no that's bad now we're in
a debate of whether the infants really
got
beheaded there's no evidence that the
infants got be
headed yeah there is evidence that the
infants got beheaded Joe Biden said they
got be headed no they were just killed
nobody beheaded them well actually if
you see the blood splatter pows it's
consistent with a beheading no no it's
no one got beheaded it's like in Iraq
when they said babies were in incubate
and this goes on all day at not these
are the people you want speaking up
these the people you want talking the
people who were 50 paragraphs on whether
the kids got beheaded or not that's
where we are and if they are beheaded
why it was kind of maybe a little
necessary well the beheadings may have
happened but
what so these are all the people that
you want adding their voices to the
great
chorus the last thing you want is people
talking about
this quiet
down quiet
down especially Israel cuz they're going
to have they're gonna have to go in
there they're gonna do they're GNA do a
little stuff in there now Gaza they're
gonna get what now this is awkward for
me the man who plan this whole thing
daif get him up I think his name is
Muhammad I don't know if his last name
is daif they call him the guest he's the
head
of Hamas he's the head of Hamas and he
is
a he's like a they call him the
ghost the guest the ghost whatever the
ghost because he's they can't get him
Muhammad daif secret of Hamas Commander
known as the guest is Israel's prime
target in this war this is a guy they
have not been able to find
forever forever over the past two
decades Israel has tried to assassinate
Muhammad daif several times maming him
in attacks and killing his wife and baby
son the commander of the Armed wing of
Hamas on Saturday inflicted in return
one of the deadliest ever Palestinian
blows on Israel the brutality of the
attacks by is Adin alasan brigades
directed by daif have shocked even
hardened Israel militants mowed down
revelers at a music festival murdered
entire communities of people on the Gaza
border da
D we know that there is little doubt
though that daif is now in the
crosshairs at the Israelis on Wednesday
Israel airri strikes hit the home of one
of his family members killing his
brother uh and his brother's wife and
children according to Palestinian media
reports and people in Gaza a spokesman
for Hamas didn't respond to a request
for comment in the end we will get not
only him but the entire leadership of
Hamas so they're going after this guy
he's and I'm not even saying this he's
renting my house in Austin and has been
for literally eight months and is a is
actually a good tenant to a point where
I'm I don't know if I'll call I don't
know if I'll call because he's actually
been fine he mows the gr like he's act
it's he's actually he's a man of Faith
he's
quiet no I don't I don't
uh I don't know if they'll get him but
that's who they want he's the guy that
planned this whole thing this they'll
probably get him they're GNA get
everybody
so it's an ugly reality now where the
you know is anyone ever going to be able
to peacefully live over there together
next to each other two-state solution
anything is anybody ever going to be
able to live over there in a
way that uh people can you know just is
it ever ever ever G to happen I it you
know maybe it will maybe it will but it
it looks like this is kind of a Line in
the Sand here mhm where it's going to
get increasingly difficult
and this war we're only a few days in
more stuff's going to
happen um so I mean they're they're
calling for this Hamas day of jihad on
October
13th I'll tell you one thing that's safe
American
colleges nobody's killing those kids
that's little Hamas over there in
TS these kids just want to be cool
they're weird asexual freaks they take
pills all day and then they see these
guys on paragliders going in and killing
people and these kids are like [__] I
just want to do something that's the
problem and and and finally people are
starting to realize that like what they
are teaching in college not this is
again it's not about per se Palestine or
isra but what they are teaching about
like what is tolerable and justifiable
violence is wild and people are now kind
of just coming around to that this idea
that during uh you know the 2016
election it was go punch a Nazi punch
anyone that disagrees with you find
somebody who disagrees with you you can
attack them words or violence respond in
kind respond with violence conservative
speakers shows up on campus you don't
like that try to kill him you know I
mean the Ben Shapiro all these little
guys Ben Shapiro's like what 120 pounds
soaking wed he walks into a room and the
entire College uh of of people trying to
kill the guy and this was and then
people on the left said this is okay
well where do you think these kids get
these [__]
ideas somebody goes to a college to
speak and they're allowed to go and
physically intimidate them and threaten
them and attack them violently and
everybody in the media goes well that's
good and then something like this
happens and everybody's shocked that
these kids think this is a great thing
that this is actually a justifiable
thing to slaughter people like this
um I you
know yeah so everybody October 13th
they're saying is the day I don't know
what I don't know
what I don't
know it was funny as there's an article
about Hamas but if you scroll down
there's actually it says Master the
steps to grow your career as a CFO and
then it says leadership Vision
confidence management strategy teamwork
and I'm like if Hamas is that organized
like I was like if Hamas is actually
that organized where they're like Vision
confidence
management but they're gonna they're
going to recruit people this is going to
be a global recruitment
campaign um I'm just hoping I'm a fan of
less death less war less death some type
of negotiation cooler heads prevailing
eventually I understand that Israel's
got to go and respond I understand that
but also we do have to think long game
here you know what what's uh what is
this going to end up being this is a
region that is never going to be
peaceful it will never be peaceful for
as long as we're on Earth it's probably
going to be a volatile combustible
region forever it's just a matter of how
volatile how combustible is it going to
spill over into a World War some people
are like well maybe Russia is trying to
get Iran to to bait the US in a
war trust me a war is the best thing for
our economy it always has been so
anybody thinking that I mean I know
people on Twitter writing that people
that think they know anything um I don't
think Russia had to bait China I could
be wrong but I don't know if Russia had
to bait Iran into funding Hamas who's
been doing it for years or I didn't know
if if Russia had to bait Hamas into
doing something that I believe they've
been planning for years and wanted to do
for years and finally had the
opportunity to do and a lot of people
the new an article just came out in the
New York Times about why Israel's
security system failed this is a one of
the most secure places supposedly on the
planet and everybody's like why the hell
didn't this
work you know Israel's military and ESPN
services are considered among the
world's best but on Saturday operational
and intelligence failures led to the
worst breach of Israeli defenses in half
a century when anything like this
happens people immediately start
thinking is it a false flag in the sense
not is it a false flag but was it
allowed to happen was this allowed to
happen I don't know anything I'm not
suggesting that I'm saying when
something so good fails people start
going hey man what why shortly before
attackers from Gaza poured into Israel
at dawn on Saturday Israeli intelligence
detected a surge and activity on some of
the Gaza militant networks at monitors
realizing something unusual was
happening agent sent an alert to the
Israeli soldiers guarding the gazan
Border according to two senior Israeli
security officials but the warning
wasn't acted upon either because the
soldiers didn't get it or the soldiers
didn't read
it shortly afterward Hamas the group
that controls Gaza sent drones to
disable some of the Israeli military
cellular communication stations and
surveillance Towers along the border
preventing the Duty Officers from
monitoring the area remotely with video
cameras the drones also destroyed remote
controlled machine guns that Israel had
installed on its border fortification
removing a key means of combating a
ground attacks this is a very well
planned well executed
attack that made it easier for Hamas
salance to approach and blow up parts of
the Border fence and bulldo it in
several places with surprising ease
allowing thousands of Palestinians to
walk through the
gaps these operational fail and
weaknesses were among a wide array of
logistical and intelligence lapses by
the Israeli security service that pav
the way for the Gaz and incursion into
Southern Israel according to four senior
Israeli security officials who spoke on
the condition of anonymity in order to
discuss a sensitive matter and their
early assessment of what went wrong so
they had a good day this is Hamas having
a good day it all worked you know I mean
truly that's what that's what it is it
worked you know they had all these ideas
and they didn't know if these things
were going to work but they actually
worked and it was obviously a bloody and
terrible day but for them you know when
you when you are trying to pull off
something of on on this level the fact
that all of these things happened and
you didn't hit a snag anywhere is
somewhat impressive so now Israel's
retaliating let's look at the Gaza Strip
right now do we have a live Gaza Strip
do have anything live we can pull up see
where because the Gaza Strip is not
doing well Israel's pounding it
obviously
um because they are now trying to take
out Hamas leadership but you know
they're going to take out a bunch of
people anyway there's going to be a lot
of Civilian casualties a lot of
kids which is
hard this is this is the tough
part you know this is the part
that
everybody even the
staunch supporters of Israel should you
know have said like let you know is
there a safe passage to Egypt for some
of the refugees here is there a way to
get them out of Harm's
Way because nobody can be happy about
the murder of women and children and you
know one thing about military-aged men
still not great you still have to
examine your head if you're really
thrilled about the death of anybody but
when you're celebrating the death of the
elderly or women or children or infants
there's something very sick you you've
dehumanized your your enemy which is
what has happened here for for a very
long time and I don't and here's what I
will say and this is unfortunate and
people are not going to be happy with
this but I do I don't think that's
one-sided I don't think the
dehumanization is one-sided I think both
of these people see each other as less
than human and I see them both as less
than human because I'm a white Christian
man we are the ones who
win no uh but what I'm saying is get the
Christians back in please and get them
all out get them all out the Christians
are coming back my fat aunt and her
husband they're going to the Holy
Land because they respect it they're not
going to do what the Palestinians do
they're not going to Stone gays and
they're not going to do what the
Israelis do do a bunch of tech startups
and then not let me host The Daily Show
my aunt and uncle are going to do is
they're going to walk around the Cave of
the whatever and they're going to
[__] eat churros or you know whatever
hummus or whatever the hell and and let
the Christians back in here okay because
apparently they need to come back
because both of you no good no
good I was thinking about going to
Israel and now I'm not even going to
go I was thinking about doing a trip
next summer and I wanted to go to Gaza
too you know me I wanted to go
everywhere I could be one of those chics
Ray looks like the blind Chic the one
with the eye from
911 but but my point is that maybe and I
know there's Christians that live there
but I don't mean them I mean middle
American Christians give it to them give
it to like the saralin types you know
the people that live in the middle of
America get them and put them there and
they're not going to have this problem
they're just going to do dumb [__]
they're going to get fat they're going
to take cruises they're going to
commercialize the [__] out of it not in
a successful way like Israel but in a
gross way like they've done to Orlando
let them do that let them do
that the Palestinian little children
would love my aunt and uncle they would
walk around the Gaza Strip with prels
and feed them like a petting
zoo and it would be be nice my aunt
would look phenomenal in a burka so
would her
husband and uh because this I'm a little
to to be honest with you I I'm a little
fed up with
everybody I'm a little mad with every
I'm more mad at Hamas now because
they're being a nut now but I'm a little
fed up with everybody I think it's high
time that the Christians come
back how about that and bring our food
like pork and
pasta what about the
Romans Romans coming
back because we do though we
need the Vatican needs to come back here
and and and and whip this planet back in
shape if the Vatican would just get
involed oh they're closing up on
something now I wonder what's about to
happen this is CRA you're watching
people get bombed this is crazy and then
there's going to be an ad for chbani
flips
in the middle of this there's going to
be an ad they're going to be like do you
like yogurt on the go chabani is not
only fun and flavorful it's chalk full
of probiotics and then you're gonna go
oh good and then you're going to turn
around and then they're going to just
it's going to be like
Hospital
school and it makes you watching this
stuff [__] your head up it's really
it's really really terrible and it's not
something that uh is is really avoidable
unless you really are going to be CR
like imagine the people that don't even
know this is going on they're the real
crazy people they're like what are you
talking about like what do you think's
going on in the Middle East they're like
what the what Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm they
have 100 offices Nationwide more than
800 lawyers with over $15 billion
recovered for over 300,000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation Morgan and Morgan has
been fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy blank is
hard meing oh God this
crap if you're ever injured you could
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com Tim
or dial pound law pound 529 from your
cell phone that's fthe people.com Tim or
pound law pound 529 from your cell this
is a paid advertisement ship station is
is so easy if you're starting an
e-commerce business the most important
thing is that your mind is free to work
on origination of business that is the
engine okay you don't need to be
worrying about the back office if orders
are getting shipped if people are happy
if things are working that's why you can
easily automate shipping tasks and
manage orders in one simple dashboard
you can quickly and easily update
crucial order information reduce errors
effortless integration everywhere you
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and more manage orders print
labels compare rates optimize every
shipment and automate delivery
notifications simple ify and automate
your shipping no matter how big your
business grows ship station has
Enterprise solutions that reduce
Warehouse costs they impove improve
profitability ship stations robust
automations and Reporting make scaling
easy and as your business grows you can
save thousands on shipping cost get
discounts up to 84% off USPS and UPS
rates over 130,000 companies have grown
their e-commerce business with ship
station and 98% of companies that stick
with ship station for year become
customers for life say your business up
for holiday season succcess with
shipstation go to shipstation.com and
use the code Tim Dylan today and sign up
for your free 60-day trial that
shipstation.com code TD l l n what are
the celebrities saying where are they on
this which ones where all of them what
do you mean which ones oh Noah snapch
didn't say I know he's a sweet guy I
feel bad what do you want you know
folks I got fans everywhere I got fans
on the
Strip you don't think anybody's paying
for that patreon on the
strip I got people on The Strip Gaza
Strip but I also have people at Tel
Aviv Noah schnap it was a lovely
statement he said we're all we all got
to stop with you know we we got it's all
a version of be nice right we should all
be nice he's a sweet guy what's he gonna
say MH you know
he's you know his family's there he goes
there he has
fun Mia khif for the porn stars out
there in you know getting a [__] in the
parag
glider I mean
it's a lot of them are putting out
statements and then retracting them like
the one I did on my Instagram that was
really funny which is like literally
this is the way celebrities talk go to
my go to my uh Instagram page cuz this
is what this is like what celebrities
when they talk this is what they sound
like because
literally not all celebrities some of
them are quite smart but a lot of them
are incredibly dumb and and you don't
know how dumb they are you would you
would you would lose faith in everything
immediately if you knew how dumb people
were but there there exists an apparatus
of people to prevent you from ever
finding out how dumb they are that's the
thing everyone thinks they're evil and
some of them are but a lot of them are
just just dumb like
finding out a few of them are evil is
people live with that they go yeah yeah
yeah they're so they're diabolical okay
but finding out how genuinely stupid a
lot of them are they're so rich and so
successful but I mean God are they
[__] dumb that would disturb be that
would bother the more um and this is the
way they talk and this I kind of parody
this I'm like I've been thinking a lot
about the events of the last few days
and I am disgusted by the hatred I
believe in love and that we need love
because love is what makes life worth
living so to the people who hate I say
maybe just love and maybe the Stars will
shine just a little bit brighter because
that's what love does it makes the Stars
remind us of how beautiful they are and
the oceans and Forest too and all the
living things and I'm sorry I posted
those five other reactions my team took
down this is what I meant to say I like
oceans thank you that's what that's the
mind your dealing with with a lot of
these celebrities but a a lot of them
have you know to their credit started to
realize now for example the Palestinians
that are surrounding the Sydney Opera
House going gas the Jews guess who's not
allowed to perform at the cdy opera
house hi hi Diana how are you oh it's
good welcome back here come come here
and sit in your Beverly Hills little mug
you like let me tell you a story okay
Diana all right
but I have a few things to say about
Israel and pal hey hey hey hey hey hey
it's not I don't think it's no no no but
I you know I dieting a man no I know but
we can't right now this is not
productive okay let me tell you do you
know the Sydney Opera House oh yes it's
in Australia yes they would not let Tim
Dylan perform there really why is it
because you say bad stuff about the
Ukraine war kind of
yes but you know who they you know who
they let outside all the Palestinians
chanting gas the
Jews oh wow that's interesting so you
were not allowed to prevent by the way
people think that I've had a total
mental collab you know if they watch
this like if they want like if by the
way if you watch this you would think
this a guy that's had a total mental
collap I'm actually here's what's crazy
I'm very
successful that's actually more disturb
I'm like incredibly successful at this
dumb thing I do but this l literally if
you just saw this like if someone walked
in here they would go this guy's totally
lost and I kind of have but they
wouldn't you know my point is that they
got the Palestinians or who I'm not
blaming them I don't know who's over
there but they're in Sydney screaming
gas to Jews outside of the Opera they
will not even let me perform at the
Opera House Okay g what were they
chanting gas to Jews yeah gas to Jew now
here's what's IC my onean show that I'm
doing is called gas the juice that's the
name of
the you're not going to get away with
jokes like that
[Laughter]
forever I don't know anymore folks I'm
just telling you what I'm what I'm where
I'm at with everything the kids in
colleges have gone insane they are
fetishizing
violence they're just ifying anything
this we're on Stolen land shit's got to
stop a lot of countries were were
founded uh in in in ways that were not
uh you know uh however you want to call
it
ideal that doesn't mean they don't have
a right to exist it does mean perhaps
they can't expand and and continually
evict people I agree with that but
Israel has a right to exist like the
United States has a right to exist this
we unstolen land is the dumbest I'm
about to leave America go to Australia
where literally every time the plane
lands it all welcome to Sydney and go we
Lo to give a whatever they say they're
like we Lo to acknowledge the past
present future Guardians of the land the
indigenous and you go hey guy will you
cut it the [__] out cut it out cut them
checks stop with this horeshit cut them
checks cut them checks give him casinos
give him museums whatever you want to do
don't make them live in in a in a
nightmare situation but stop no one's
giving the land back stop with the
stolen land dummies the dumbest people
in the world go we're on Stolen land
yeah most of us are it's the dumbest
thing ever that [__] fat white women
say when they've run out of things to
say like we're stolen
land yeah so and you're gonna
leave I'm just saying these guys got to
figure it
out they got to figure it out not going
to
be you're not going to find
someone as articulate as
me you know what I mean you're just
usually someone's just GNA go start
killing
people but what I'm offering is the
third way the way of speak the talk the
speaking I'm offering the you know sort
of the uh you know just kind of fireside
chat where everybody can figure it out
and this is murder it's not you know we
cannot uh call this anything else right
we cannot we cannot say that this is
some typ people are messaging me Well
everybody's got a
problem um we cannot excuse
this we don't have to agree with the
government of Israel you can't excuse
the behavior that's you know if you go
to tough's university you [__] [__]
you could who's never been in a fist
fight in your life you cannot excuse the
behavior in the same way that you cannot
also long for an unending you know war
in Gaza that kills all of the people
that live there you can't I I understand
revenge is what people want and I
understand that for a brief period
that's going to happen the security
system you know is necessary to sh that
up it's necessary to diminish hamas's
ability to do this again we all get it
but you know you you you have to yeah
tough students for justice in Palestine
group group is ripped for obscene
comments about hamas's terrorist attacks
in
um Israel well it's a lot of Jewish
people that give these schools money you
know who's not giving Harvard money my
mom and
dad you know who's not giving Yale money
or NYU money my family so all the Jewish
people that give these [__]
people money maybe put your wallet back
in your pants how about that at my work
because there's not going to be that's
who you're getting the money
from you know you're not getting it from
me I dropped out of Community College as
you may have noticed by this 45 minute
up and down rant what he's done here
with this routine which is kind of
really a just a technical thing that he
does is he he he's spaced out these
Maneuvers quite far from each other so
it really gives the judges a chance to
enjoy each one of them on its merits a
lot of people put them together so that
they could kind of get them over with
but what he does is he does one and then
takes a while to just kind of throw it
to a little bit of a crowd-pleasing
dance before he does another it's a
riskier move but he seems more
comfortable that way I'll tell you this
folks
um I have no um wish for anyone to be
harmed and that's the thing I I have a
lot of Jewish friends that are beside
themselves um
and I know a lot of people that take a
different you know they have a different
view of the of the crisis over there
because they're Muslims they're Arab and
they've grown up with entire different
education and you
know there's not going to be a solution
here that anybody thinks about right now
what we should prevent is a nuclear
war we should prevent a nuclear War we
should pre prevent World War III a
larger War we should prevent uh innocent
people getting killed on either
side we
should try to Envision uh you know what
we can do to make that region less
volatile but it doesn't see it doesn't
with being honest with you you're my
audience I'm going to be honest I don't
think it's ever going to
work I don't think it's ever going to
work like I don't know if you would
bring all these people from all over the
world into America that have all these
different cultures some of them are
going to assimilate and respect Western
culture some of them will not and you're
gonna have to deal with that and they're
going to be chanting de to this one and
de to that one and you know there is
just not much you're GNA be able to
do if you bring in all of these
different cultures with the hope that
some of them are going to assimilate
because cultures have assimilated in the
past that seems to be the hope but then
some of them going to chant Gast to
Jews outside of the Opera
House so everybody that says well if we
said one thing about immigration if
people said well immigration might have
some negatives every person every celeb
every left [__] lib on Twitter was like
what do you mean you Nazi
scum and they were like no everybody
comes to to these places for the same
reason they because their daughter wants
to see Barbie like and
then fast forward those some of those
people are chanting gas to Jews outside
of a Opera
House are they being good
Australians is that it's it hasn't been
a stellar week for
multiculturalism it just hasn't been it
doesn't mean there can't be a better
weeks there can be some good
weeks this has not been a great week for
multi doesn't mean that it's a
completely doomed project it means that
you're just going to live with some
level of it not working out quite as
well as you thought it's like a marriage
it's just not going to work out quite as
well as you thought because when you're
high and you're just tweeting and you're
like everyone's coming to my country to
listen to my cun which is what all these
people
thought everybody thought everybody was
coming here they want to see you two at
the sphere just like we do and then some
of them actually just wanted to go and
chant gas to
juice that's what some of them wanted to
do there did was there was there was
that a test when everybody came in was
there was there what's your idea of a
fun Saturday
night are you a are you a homebody or do
you want to go outside the opera house
and yell gas the
juice just live with it not working out
quite as well as you
thought if you think it's a good idea to
keep invading as Steve sailor said you
might not like Steve S most of you
retards don't know who he is here's the
point the people that would hate me for
mentioning his name don't know who he is
here's the point if you're going to
continually invade the world and then
invite the world if you're going to
knock over all these countries pop up
all these dictators the Middle East does
cling to some an archaic form of
religion of theocracy but a lot of
that's because we propped up a lot of
these goons to begin with because they
were doing business with us so they
oppressed their people and kept their
mouth shut and they were able to uh do
our bidding and work with our
multinational
corporations Iran is a perfect example
from that you look at a progressive
country that goes you know that turns on
a dime and now is a is a huge problem an
incubator of fundamentalist philosophy
if you keep doing this if you keep
knocking over these countries for the
small benefit of a small group of people
that live in America the people that
really Feast on the on the corpse of the
dying Empire you know like the people
that are really really Mak and it's not
just a small group by the way and that's
the other
misconception you know there's a lot of
people making money off this Empire it's
not just it's not just the GU the ones
in the top make more than the rest of us
but if we all want to adjust our
lifestyle
downward you can go to countries with
that military-industrial complex they
have one nice restaurant called Noma and
they live in tiny little boxes and they
eat caterpillars and they have a nice
Christmas Market and it's called Norway
or Denmark it doesn't matter the point
is if you want to live in a 6,000 squ
foot house in the middle of Texas where
nine of the rooms are unused and drive a
big car that you can get into an
accident in even if you're drunk and
you'll still be okay because you can't
afford the spinal surgery there you're
going to need if you flip it if you want
to live that type of life if you want to
spend thousands of dollars on highin
rate credit card revolving debt to buy
garbage fat chairs for your disgusting
family to sit in if you want to go out
to restaurants like majanos in the
Cheesecake Factory and eat plastic
lasagna full of Poison every day
someone's got to pay for
that someone's got to pay for that kind
of life
okay and it's not
just the people at the top that take a
lot of The Spoils of the way we've lived
but if you're going to keep going out
into the world and knocking these places
over and then inviting everybody in and
hoping it works out and going well it
might work well it might work well it'll
be an
adventure it'll be an ADV and it keep
making
movies you know that
romanticize uh
whatever this Collision of cultures
that's fun it's sexy and fun but it's
not so much fun when people chanting gas
to Jews outside of the Opera House it
will not let me
perform so that's really the way it
looks it's not only the way it looks
it's the way it
is we've invited a lot of these issues
here we've brought them here are
unending unwavering support for Israel
without giving them any Hardline in the
sand instructions saying we you
cannot expand you cannot do this you
cannot do that
American uh money will not be there if
you do these things
um
also having an immigration
policy that just basically says hey if
you can cheat your way into this country
you can live here if you can cheat your
way in you can live here we don't really
care what you believe we assume you love
us we assume you love us in everything
we love that's why you're here we assume
you love us that you're coming because
you love us that's what we assume
because we're narcissists no matter what
we are we are narcissists and it is it
is impossible to believe that you
wouldn't be coming here just loving us
don't you love us but apparently not
everybody loves it not everybody loves
us and not everybody's here uh to go to
the Fright Night not everybody's there
to go to the [__] Halloween
Spooktacular haunted house some people
are there to chant Gast to
Jew yeah I mean that's what it is so all
the people
that uh say only positive things
about uh these um experiments these
large scale social experiments which is
what immigration is at to a certain
point it becomes an experiment we're
trying it out we're try it out and it
might work it it's worked in the past to
certain degrees for certain people more
than others but it certainly worked and
now we're going well this might work too
it may may
not but really my final word here
is
love we need it go do we need it or
not we need it and I don't you know I
just don't we need a gun that shoots
it we need a gun that shoots love if I
was
God if I was God I would just every it
would it would just be a big party over
there if I can make Israel a big party
if I could get every American
corporation and just go into the Gaza
Strip and just make it into a big mall
so that they could enjoy it everybody
could work at a Lowe's be
divorced you know because that's the
best the best reality in America is just
to work it a Lowe's and be
divorced and have a kid that doesn't
hate you I mean of sure people do better
than that here but on average on average
the best you can do in our country is to
work in a Lowe's that is located in an
outlet mall 45 minutes from your house
and have a daughter that doesn't
absolutely hate
you and you got a few nice friends at
the
Lowe's you got a few nice
friends and you you don't see each other
that much out of work you did one time
but it was kind of weird you got a few
of the guys together and you went to a
restaurant called Yard House Google it
I'm not doing that whole thing again but
you went to Yard House and you got
chicken nachos and it was fun enough it
was fun
enough and you kind of see a woman who
you think might be seeing someone else
she said she'll never live with anyone
else again and never get remarried she
put the boundaries up immediately which
you thought was a little harsh up front
but you kind of like it now she's a
little cold and stares off she smokes a
lot and says she has no plans on
stopping that is the best you're going
to do in this country on average for the
most part you work at a Lowe's and
you're divorced you date a woman who's a
smoker and has no plans unstopping and
she says I like waking up
alone your daughter doesn't completely
hate you she pities you which you think
might be a little
worse but you're not bleeding out in the
Gaza
Strip and that's the promise
that we can make is if you get it
together out there you
nuts if you get it together relax with
the
religion on both sides relax with all
the Weaponry relax with the killing if
you're
lucky one day you will be driving alone
45 minutes to work in a
Lowe's your daughter will call you she
will say I'm going away for the weekend
but I'll call you when I get back I
really miss you I love you
Dad you will say thank you
honey you will put your phone
down that smoker that woman you're
dating will also call you she'll say I'm
around tonight that's his romantic as
she gets and you'll put your phone down
and you'll think to yourself you know
what it's not that bad and you'll never
see the teenage driver coming you'll
never see the teenage driver coming
you'll smile thinking about your
daughter and the somewhat mediocre sex
you'll have with that [__] later on
you'll never see that teenage driver
coming you'll hear the
smack and you'll feel the
glass and a few of those shards of
assass will get into your smile but you
went out nice you went out good and
they'll wonder where you are tonight at
Lowe's but they won't call you they
won't call you your phone won't ring and
you knew they wouldn't call you as you
lay there dying you go they won't call
they'll just think it's one of those
nights that's the American win so if you
get your [__] act together out there
in the desert you could
have that